[Music]
it's going to be a beautiful wedding
here you are standing on the precipice
of something so much bigger than anyone
here
but always remember you are not alone i
don't think that we met i'm sarah
niles hi hi
[Music]
it's gonna be a beautiful wedding
good day so far today tomorrow it's all
the same you
what is going on hey get out of the
water
i guess you followed me it's one of
those infinite time loop situations you
might have heard about
that i might have heard about yeah
[Music]
the second you fall asleep it all just
goes back to the start i drove all the
way back home
to austin and i still woke up here one
time i smoked a bunch of crystal and
made it all the way to equatorial guinea
it was a huge waste of time
well then what's the point of flipping
we kind of have no choice but to live
no i'm gonna get out of this suit
yourself
see you tomorrow
so now what do we do you just have to
embrace the fact that nothing matters do
you sleep with people in here
great question i have but it takes a lot
of work
yeah i got in it's the first dance and
that's a deal breaker
that didn't work let's waste some
[Music]
to time know the official he's got a bag
of sweets in his pocket
you're right got him
everything that we are doing is
meaningless
i hope it's not all meaningless at least
you have each other
nothing worse than going through this
[ __ ] alone
a bomb in the cake don't worry i used to
be a bomb guy
stand back
[Music]
you